Bayesian ISM infrequent ISM are often
characterizes enemies or rivals in some
sense and one of the things we want to
talk about the main thing one - what
today is how how the two can be used
together to improve and augment models
both using using one or the other
we're particular going to focus on
survival analysis and we we think this
is very important and generally relevant
to a lot of people because estimating
time to events is something that is
ubiquitous and marketinvoice we've used
it we use it in our risk processes we
use it to estimate probability of
companies defaulting at some time in the
future what's looking and applying it to
improving marketing conversion yeah so
things like medical trials customer
lifetime value risk a company going bust
time for a customer to convert time for
a tree to fruit time for a counter sit
down it's particularly interesting study
that someone had done predicting when
items go out of stock I think there's a
talk tomorrow
using survival a notice for exactly this
survive analysis techniques basically
give you a better handle on these
problems that aren't really any other
methods that you can use on this kind of
data so our objective today is that we
in this tutorial we take you through an
end-to-end analysis process right from
you know dealing with the raw data and
getting that into a good usable
tractable form I'm going to fit three
different categories of models and you
should leave today confident you can
apply what you've learned on your own
problems yes before I go into what we're
going to discuss today as and I I'm
Jacob and this is Jake it has been quite
confusing distinction many people who
I've been here but we are different
people and
probably and yeah and we're promoting
marketing voice and dating and marketing
noise yeah so today that's bring me five
steps setting up getting things
installed getting things running in in
your notebook cleaning the data getting
it getting from raw data and something
slightly cooked so we can start to use
apply models to it then we're gonna just
do most obvious kind of frequentist
naive statistics and maybe see what the
problems are there then we're going to
go Bayesian for the first time then
we're going to actually extend what we
can do with that model by going to a
four cuentas model the Cox proportional
hazards model which is probably most
famous survival analysis model and then
we're going to go even more Bayesian
from there and that'll be quite exciting
one together yeah so has everyone is
everyone in the slack Channel okay well
either go to the slack channel which has
a link to all the resources that you're
going to need or go to Jacob Mann calm
Jake look Jacob forward slash post /pi
data and that should give you pretty
much everything you need it's in it's
called Bayesian underscore survival
that's got the link in it yeah and so
what's on that page we've got the data
you need with a hyperlink there and
we've got a selection of workbooks this
is basically so that you can we'll start
from the base workbook and if you fall
behind or you don't quite complete the
exercise you can get you can go into the
next workbook and still you know keep up
with it or we don't want to just have
people not just falling behind again in
bored
and then as you know there's a kind of
full version at the end yeah yeah we
need there are three libraries that you
need lifelines hi MC and a new library
which Jake will talk about called PI B
ma all these can and should be installed
using pip so can everyone maybe who's
planning following on do that and get
the data it's not yeah to be clear it's
um it's PI mc2 not not PI mt3 that's the
important point and that's the only do
we need a Fortran compiler no attending
say what
can you install GCC no Niro if ever seen
before I would have you got have you got
have you got can you maybe install GCC
that should have a [ __ ] on 4chan
compiler my den if you can do that with
is that Mac maybe Bruins just try brew
install GCC its installed
what ok so just write did ok I think if
you've GT should have a full chunk of
butter with witches
oh so IMC is actually pre-built on
condor so if you if you try and Condor
install that then
so in terms of running the notebooks
like the way it's setup at the moment is
a probably easiest just to download the
base one save it to your computer put it
wherever you're running your anaconda
instance and then load it up in the
browser so you should look this
essentially so you should have on screen
pretty much what I have on screen are
you having any luck with conduct okay I
mean the first bit of the presentation
won't require PMC or any piece of the
libraries because we're gonna start on
data cleaning so I guess it kind of
makes sense while it's installing that
we move on to the next step um there was
some debate about whether we wanted to
include this data cleaning step I think
it's very important it's very easy at
these presentations to come to see
something and then go home and not be
able to implement it yourselves
that's explicitly what we don't want and
survival analysis just pose some
different problems when you're
processing data you need to something's
definitely cheating to be aware of them
the big thing about survival data which
marks it from were the types of data
it's what's called censoring by if
you're looking at use a lifetime for
example you'll see when some users sub
using your product but you won't
necessarily see when all of them do and
this causes issues because the ones that
you don't see are likely to be the
longer lifetimes so the longer somebody
lives the more likely it is that you
won't see them died essentially and this
causes selection bias if you use
traditional techniques I'm the data set
is split to look as much like DCMS path
to conversion as possible without being
like to tie downs the details good
question
do you send me is Google's display
advertising tool so we're going to talk
about advertising data we're going to be
talking about people's path to
conversion so when we show someone had
for how long do we expect it to be until
they convert in the data each conversion
has a unique ID and between one and two
rows for every individual ID the first
row will be
when they see our advert for the first
time and then there's an optional
second-row for if we see them convert
and that second row date/time will be
the conversion day time I'd say this
this is actually pretty unuseful for us
to do any analysis on so we want to like
kind of pivot this up so we want to say
for each user
what was that life time and whether we
saw them die and that's kind of the
first step to take this raw output tax
from the website download it and turn it
into this form here it'd be really
helpful for later on if you convert the
agent right if you convert the age and
mail and search and brand to in
otherwise it'll cause nasty type errors
so yeah have a go at that
yeah it's also worth noting that the end
date is this particular date time here
which is useful for observing how long
people were a customer or how long they
had seen the advert for if they haven't
converted so on the website there's the
download here just right click Save Link
As
or yes or I guess crash hey yeah it
doesn't really matter where that goes
like as long as it's on your computer
somewhere you can reference it
that's mistake
yeah if anyone has any questions I can
come
so I see
she listened the fire run once like in
case anyone's having difficulty download
it from the website
yes indeed if anyone was at the Panthers
talk I have to confess I abandoned
pundits just read it through
there's something about 3,000 rows so
just in terms of example like this first
ID here we're seeing only one row for it
that means that they saw an adverb but
they didn't convert so we know when they
first interacted with us but there is no
end points they're censored okay
aye sir yep see
it already I'm so we're trying to this
date runs like if you download it so
we're trying to transform that from or
like a traditional or out we can and
it's not crucial to the mission it's
just is showing that there are by unique
considerations like it's not a free link
you just to play your traditional yeah I
prefer this like I think it's chopped
the window
it makes you feel any better this is
much easier than IMC 3 which we like to
not use this impossible so I run
seriously on my own computer through
that I just assumed that it be favorable
to install an 8 yeah we don't know
trouble getting you just reject onto the
screen
I basically speed things alone I've got
an example of how I did it
this is like a wildly inefficient
solution to the problem I tried to do
pandas it turned out to be too complex
which is a nightmare
so conceptually it comes across it says
for each row am i a new conversion if it
is a new conversion it records the the
starting date time it's the date times
the advert if it's not if it's a
completely new one then it essentially
marks the the previous row as sensor
data I don't think it's vastly important
that we actually go through this
ourselves it's just useful to be aware
that this is difficult it's like it is
something which is a substantive change
from normal data sources so you should
be prepared for this runtime investment
in sorting out your data as in all data
analysis through
and then the data ends up looking
something like yeah I've got heard where
this lifetime figure is in days okay so
has everyone and if they haven't done
did themselves how they have we got for
the next version of the notebook that
yes so it took me a farewell to do it
you can just catch back up using the
second
yeah so there's there's a workbook
called data cleaning done which just
takes you to this point with with the
data getting done the same will be true
throughout the presentation you fall
behind okay yeah so now I want everyone
to just how would you we've got this
we've got this clean dead set
what kind of statistics might want to go
out of it and can we can you just
compute a few of those and that should
be pretty pretty straightforward and we
might just have spoiled it for you but
there we go can anyone tell me what this
is telling us and maybe also I mean I'm
kind of leading you on here but what
what isn't this turning us anyone got
anything to say about this just this
just doing the media and doing the mean
on this dataset what what other what are
the risks of doing that in terms of
trying to trying to know what's going on
correct sorry yeah
the main convention is is there is the
lifetime money so just bear in mind what
we're talking about with the with this
censored data
what yeah I mean one of the one of the
basic problems with just just if we
could if we stopped the analysis here
and we wanted to to estimate the average
lifetime of one of one of these users
what what what might we not be taking
into account
yeah that's that's definitely important
yet we don't see for distribution and
also there's massive selection book
sorry
it seemed that which I mean we're just
with sorry and this is a bit misleading
where we're only really thinking about
estimating the lifetimes here I'm
leaving I mean we just we just did a
somewhat dated frame but the lifetimes
what we're we're thinking about here
yeah so that I mean the main point is
that's of two major points one is this
we've got a real problem with selection
bias in our sample and also these these
are point estimates we don't have any we
don't there's the uncertainty in the
testament is completely invisible to us
at this point and that's bad because
yeah that's bad so at this point this is
where we're going to first go Bayesian
because going Bayesian allows us to know
to make that uncertainty visible which
is really important
okay so at this point we're going to
introduce the library IMC and I think I
should also give a shout out to come
Davidson Pilon because like his works
definitely been a massive inspiration of
mine and also largely this example is
very much copied from his blog post we
shall find here I definitely recommend
reading it and also his book Bayesian
methods for hackers it's good stuff so
what we have at the moment is a point
estimate of the median and the mean and
we want to estimate what the average
lifetime of the user is using
traditional techniques traditional ways
of thinking it's not clear where we go
from here so basically with some it's a
pretty good suggestion
one of the core essences are Bayesian
ISM is thinking about data generation
processes right how is the data that I'm
seeing being generated and how can i
model them what we want to do is to find
we want to assume that there is some
underlying distribution of users and how
quickly they are going to convert and we
want to identify what they're the best
distribution is for this and basically
instance a really good fit for this the
nice thing about pmc is that allows us
to encode our assumptions really really
straightforwardly so we say that there
is some lifetime which is this this is
what we observe and if this line here is
somewhat complex and I wouldn't really
try and read too much into it it's just
something to hack around the fact that
we're using sensor data so I mean just
kind of take that thread what we're
saying is that there is some
distribution of lifetimes and that they
are censored we want to identify what
distribution is driving this for this
process and pretty much throughout this
entire talk we're going to assume this
wiebel distribution this is in no way a
substantive distri assumption what we're
saying is that there is some
distribution that we can parameterize it
in some way and like it's in this broad
family and the reason that we want this
is so that we can break down
distribution space into two different
numbers
we will distribution has two parameters
it has alpha and visa like this concept
concerned a bit intimidating I imagine a
lot of you are more familiar with normal
distributions like in some sense you can
think about from beta as analogous to
the mean standard deviation by there's
not a one-to-one mapping there or the
core idea is you can describe the entire
distribution using these two things
so rather than means center distribution
your alpha and beta the second big thing
about base in ISM is this concept of
moving from priors to posteriors so we
need to specify going in what we think
out from beta L now in this case I
probably don't have like any great idea
it could be really anywhere just nothing
to add so I'm going to choose this very
flat distribution and uniforms really
good choices that like get essentially
assigns every possibility equal
probability later on in the talk we'll
see like how we can play with this so if
we did know a lot going in so we didn't
several studies beforehand we can change
this to be a lot more informative so the
final step is once we built up this this
idea we know that we have a Weibull
distribution we know that there are two
parameters alpha beats that we want to
estimate we build up this MCMC object
essentially we just pump in these three
parameters and then we take loads of
random guesses or what Alfre beta could
be now the actual technology that drives
this is quite complex I've no real
intention of going into it now it's a
really beautiful piece of theory but
like all you kind of need to know is
that we're taking random samples and
getting closer and closer to what
they're most likely distribution is so
in some senses similar like gradient
descent where you are moving from areas
of low probability to areas of high
probability
every guess that we take gets us closer
to this true ideal distribution so this
is obviously like a completely faked
example how many of you have now got PI
MC and soul
all right that is a lot better than I
thought it's going to be five minutes
ago
um when you have run MCMC in terms of
actually getting the output there are
two really nice functions thankfully and
this is an absolute lifesaver you can
use this map plot to to plot the
distribution and you can also get the
trace what the traces is the history of
all the guesses that we've made so if we
guess one we guess two we get four we
guess five they'll give you a list of
those it's kind of useful for seeing the
overall value so you'll see that your
cells to go through all right so we're
gonna hand back over to you because it's
supposed to be interactive um the first
question is to take this where we've
generated this data like as a toy
example and replace it with the data
that we have processed and cleaned or
you've just taken from the website if
they don't happen so I mean the main
things are to replace this and so you
get the sensor variable this variable
here
and that lifetime variable
can people read the code on the screen
okay well I mean also everyone's got
notebooks right
this might be good moment frisk around
and how people yeah so just we got bit
of time too
so naive
how are people getting on with is anyone
stuck on anything major yeah that's
gonna be that the big focus is the next
section
yeah
okay so to speed things along a bit
probably worth like showing the our code
for this it's probably worth trying to
hack it together so that it works on
your computer as well pending the fact
you have the installations correctly
because I mean this is pretty much the
foundation of how to run Bayesian models
so looking at the the original code had
last time what's relevant is this sensor
which you can think of as essentially
the inverse of an event something
censored if we didn't see the event and
we want to get a list of whether or not
each person was censored so we take the
event and we essentially converting it
to this zero one and then the only other
real changes you have to make to that
example code is to serve in what was
lifetime into this is this data frame so
when I using our data and we're using
our sensor information the rest of is
just going to run traffic noise
well crayon to it
it's kinda nerdy so working for cycling
okay and we will be using this to the
entire presentation we switch onto the
actually on two lifelines maybe that you
could hear
is this working for people or people at
this kind of stage and if you must be
stuck then we can definitely help we can
talk through things a bit more
all right so if you have got that
successfully to run what you should have
is this MCMC object which you can do
trace and alpha on this alpha is derived
from the name that we gave it here so if
I'd call this Jake for this column then
in the trace I'd refer to the first
variable which is Salford by Jake and
the second one by Colin and then each of
these traces will give you a list where
and the length of the list is the number
of samples it so kind each element is
the value for alpha or beta on that
iteration of the algorithm now bearing
in mind that we can calculate the median
of weeble distribution by this formula I
guess the next step is to try and get
something meaningful out like it's not
too meaningful to know alpha beta is
what we want to know is the median so we
want to use those trace outputs to
calculate this median value I mean if
you're still getting this to work and
it's probably more important from them
it's also worth mentioning if you are
massively stuck at this point there is
one more notebook that's going to
essentially have done these so the rest
of the presentation won't be closed off
it's probably worth mentioning the the
actual output that this will produce
looks trashy it looks terrible
so if you think that you've got it wrong
because it doesn't look nice then I
wouldn't worry too much we're going to
like resolve those issues in the next
couple of stages the presentation I was
just talking to how you'd rename
yeah
right so walking around it seemed like a
lot of people had some output have you
be able to turn that output into traces
are we okay to like cover how we
calculate the median no trace yes no
traces
not a bad right return
we take alright so just to keep things
moving i calculating the median it's
nowhere near as difficult as it sounds
or looks like you can quite simply just
loop over all the samples each of those
samples is a guess at the true values
and if you sweep across all those
guesses then you get this estimate of
what the median is and you get this nice
distribution so some of the guesses will
be too high some of the guesses will be
too low but the main weight of the
distribution will be the correct value
the nice thing is you'll also get to see
this this spread from the histogram so
going through the code this line here is
just a straight transformation of B to
the x log two one to the alpha so beta
times log 2 to the power 1 over alpha
and then this function justice of this
comprehension over the whole thing and
if you have other metrics you want to
calculate for the data you can do very
much exactly the same so you just change
this function and then loop over and
importantly there's no aggregation
happening here so it literally can't be
anything if you want to do the mean you
could just sub it in or the range or any
of these things as long as it's
I know how we're getting the traces here
alpha and beta for those who aren't
familiar with how zip works it takes two
lists and essentially pairwise combines
them so it's just applying the first
element of this the first element of
this and the first element of this to
this function and then the second
element of this and this to the function
and so on okay next part of this section
yeah
so try adjusting the number the number
of samples for burning and thinning can
anyone tell me what either burning or
thinning or both okay well so burning
you can think of with we're taking all
these samples and it's converging
towards towards the correct value if we
but if we burn some of those samples we
basically cut them out and that yeah
that's see that's useful thing to do
thinning can we we got here
I see so how would you okay yeah I did
if if people people got talking Loeb is
running it this is easier to see
visually but you know was where's the
parameter that we can changed where's
the where's the bone hunting
someday from that but yeah okay yeah
sorry so the if you just passed these
into the into the sample method here
that's how you adjust the parameters
thinning is basically designed to reduce
autocorrelation and it I mean how would
you describe how does that's basically
so the problem that you'll have seen
with your diagrams if you've run them in
the bottom left you have this
autocorrelation diagram which shows how
correlated all of our guesses are
together so the way the MCMC works is it
moves around neighborhoods of the
probability distribution so which guess
will inherently be close to the guesses
it's already made and this is really bad
if we want to estimate the convergence
because we're not moving across the
whole distribution very rapidly so
there's a lot less information for each
sample
well thinning does is just says if I'm
correlated with something that went just
before me then throw that thing away and
keep only every twentieth sample so you
essentially get rid of this
autocorrelation because I know not
really correlated to twenty time periods
realistically yeah
yeah the first thousand
and you could do that they wouldn't
necessarily be very useful the reason
you want burners because you're looking
for the point of conversion converging
--less convergence and when you start
you can start anywhere and it takes a
while like are you familiar gradient
descent gradient descent ok so I mean
the general idea is you're moving from
low probability to high probability and
you could start in like real dead water
territory and the paths are getting to
your high probability isn't particularly
useful like if you drop somewhere else
you'd have a different path and that's
how the opposite of conversions so if
you just get rid of that initial bit
then exactly so for those of you who
have this running definitely try and
play with burn and thin like I think
it's nice to start with very low values
of both of them and see how ramping it
affects like you want as low values for
these as possible
I realistically you don't want to be
throwing away every xx every 19 out of
20 samples so you can keep that lower
than it's better see you seems to kind
of play the parameters
I mean to be right so the question is
like what's a good amount of water
correlation was a bad amount of
autocorrelation I need to be honest I'd
keep it at 20 because that nukes
autocorrelation is an issue what if you
forgot with and the thin parameter here
so that says I'm only interesting every
xx sample yeah and these models are so
simple that the computer can just smash
them out if you're running something a
bit more complex there'd be more of a
it's the correlation of each sample to
the ones that went before it and that's
clearly bad right if you're trying to
get independent samples from something
so jumping ahead in my little notebooks
schedule and if you're stuck or behind
then I definitely cause you to the same
remember you can open different versions
of the presentation at the website so if
you're way behind I'd recommend
installing John IMC done - which is
where we're currently at the
presentation
if people have assigned to see the
effects of adjusting burners then you
might want to also try adjusting the
prior and see how that effects
and timelines do you think it's pretty
good yeah
there's a section here on how playing
with the prize impacts the overall so
we're just going to talk about varying
priors a bit more later on so we're just
going to move past this section in the
interest of time so we can get on to the
Cox proportional hazards model now we
are at this point where we're returning
to frequent ism with probably the most
famous survival analysis model as
everyone everyone's still lifelines by
now most people good okay
yeah the documentation is here it should
be very easy to use yeah so what I mean
I guess we we should say a bit about why
we want to use this at this point at the
moment we can't really look at how
covariates are affecting are affecting
our estimate so we you can the Cox
proportional hazards model is kind of
analogous to like a linear regression
for this kind of data for this kind of
survival analysis data yeah I mean
that's and that's obviously something
that is desirable and crucially the form
that it converts at all so yeah so using
lifelines I have a look at the
documentation and see if you can plot
the baseline survival function and
predict functions for particular set of
features the and then the third question
as well block this function for two
different set of features these three
things should be reasonably
straightforward using the documentation
I think we're trying to show how do you
really big real-life analysis yeah well
as in yeah I mean I guess the point the
reason we're giving you this and showing
and not showing you exactly how to do it
it's because this is this is how you
would you would deal this kind of remote
life right you saw a library look at the
documentation we hope you've chosen a
library that is well documented and well
written in the first place and hopefully
this will empower you to think it's
actually not that difficult to do so
there you go okay so the relevant
session is going to be a survival
regression
all right he's terrible
if anyone has any questions just raise
your hand we'll come around
is it in something so okay it makes you
feel any better in the process of
creating this I had to do exactly the
same thing
just some interest how many of you in
the room have done any kind of survival
analysis before one
and force would to make things be taken
here
I hope they shouldn't be like too crazy
difficult
I was very concerned we don't have 45
minutes I was not
yes but it's just it's just worth
reinforcing this at this stage we've
talked about in the in the beginning
about how Bayesian is meant for
quentin's and were not kind of like
opposites or like a choice you had to
make you know you have to go down one
path and not the other what we've just
done is we've start we've started in
very naive kind of traditional
frequentist basic statistics we've moved
to two Bayesian model and now we work
we've come back to a frequentist model
to taping analysis further to do
something we couldn't do in the previous
kind of baby Bayesian model
which okay has anyone has anyone got
summary statistics table yes one hand
okay that's that's that's a result I
think which is
okay I think I think it looks like quite
a few people have got have got the some
of their statistics now I just one thing
I want to say about these
which [ __ ] down right
was
yeah so this this here is the answer
since I know that's what
so if you succeed in bringing this
yourself you'll know that it's like a
halter and fasten MCMC because it's like
properly for cuentas toilets just trying
to maximise its not doing this whole
something process
could anyone who's got the
No
all right there we go so here's here's
our nice kind of summary Cystic table
this looks probably quite familiar to
any of you who've done kind of standard
regression the only made interesting
important thing to note is that you
probably would use not the first column
but the second exponential function
coefficients because that means they
they all come out positive and then if
we go we're going to skip to the next
so yeah so I guess the poor important
concepts in surviving artists are the
hazard hazard and the and of okay but
the yeah the the the so yeah we have we
have a baseline survival which is
effectively the in the inset and then we
have the survival with as affected as
influenced by their cocoa various so if
we plot this
yeah and you can see how much fun this
is
so now we want to plot two different
curves for different different
covariance against one another you get
that Kenny will think how we would get
the odds ratio for I've get for these
two but these two variables yeah very
good and that looks like this okay so at
this point we've got quite a nice model
that enables us to see the effect of
covariates on the SPO function but there
are still problems that you might that
might not be immediately obvious but the
fundamental problem that we're going to
think about now is model uncertainty and
this is something that a lot of
traditional statistical techniques just
don't even consider at all and jakers so
traditionally when you have a model you
calculate some some test statistic about
how confident you are whether it's like
t-test Peters these kind of things and
to do that you use the standard
deviations of the coefficients in your
model the problem is that this only
takes into account and the the error
condition on the model being correct if
your model is wrongly specified or has
the wrong covariance it doesn't have
covariance which are in fact important
then your model will be invalid and your
standard errors won't be right this is a
big issue because you can't test whether
your model is correct using the the
standard errors because if it's wrong it
will be giving you wrong numbers how to
actually deal with this in practice the
most common approach is to essentially
pick selections of different covariance
and run them in the model and then see
how they compare against each other so
often you'll have the whole model and
you'll take one away you'll take one
away take one away or you might add one
back in and one back in and see whether
the addition or removal of that variable
affects the models performance in a
significant way and then at the end of
that process you say this was the best
model it performs the best and therefore
I will accept it as truth and then you'd
go and you perform your tests the issue
that you have is that you are just
discounting this this probability of
your model is wrong and let's be honest
almost all statistical models ever made
are invalid in some way is so easy to
invalidate them so what we want to do is
to account for this uncertainty and
Bayesian ISM is a great tool to do this
and this is a really nice example of how
for cuentas and basis and can work
together we've got 90 percent of the way
using for quent ISM and we can automate
it really easily using Bayesian methods
how we're going to do it sounds very
very simple I thought it was gonna be
very very simple and then the must turn
out to be a nightmare but there the good
news is that we can essentially
outsource as complexity to SATs packages
it's easy enough and the output is an
API that looks pretty much exactly like
the the Cox proportional hazards one but
instead of just taking the most likely
model or the model you select it
essentially averages across all models
weighted by how likely that model was so
we have two or three different good
models models which kind of captures
something about the world but we're not
100% sure that they're right we can say
well I'll give X percent of this wipe
Center this M percent to this according
to how likely those models are now you
might be asking how do I work out how
likely a model is given the data is kind
of fiddly you don't have to worry about
it too much in the back end there's some
like maths the approximations but the
core point is it just says the better
model the more weight I'm going to give
it and the advantage of this is it
allows us to see like how robust our
models are like how sensitive they are
to our model
as with the [ __ ] so the API for this
library it's designed to be as close to
the Cox proportional hazards as one as
possible in fact in the absolute extreme
case where I said there is only one
model that I consider to be even vaguely
plausible then it essentially is the Cox
model because you can think of that
weighted average you have one model
which has probability 1 all the other
models have probability 0 when I do that
weighted average I'm just gonna get back
that one model so here is how you would
fit it this is the third model we
mentioned at the start called PI PMA
it's essentially a port of an AR library
called B MA but a partial one it only at
the moment deals with survival analysis
so I need to run it we just imported
this Li and then it's the same name same
fit takes the same parameters so you got
your data frame the name of your
lifetime column and the name of your
event con the only difference is this
and you think here called priors if you
want you can just run it like that and
it will assume this default prior set
well this prior set is saying is that
going in I have no opinions about what
the model should look like and we can
vary this according to what we actually
think so we're looking at say the
effects of smoking on cancer we can say
I actually consider to be very very
likely the smoking should affect cancer
so give that very high probability and
that allows you to like kind of narrow
down space
in addition to just trading off
different variables you can also do
something that looks like this if you
assign every variable a low probability
of being in the model what that says is
that there aren't some variables I
consider more likely than others but I
think that the true model should be very
parsimonious so the probability of any
one variable being included it's not 0.3
going in that means the models that
produce at the end will have fewer
variables then if we assume you're
playing five now on the spin say I want
a very complex model because I want to
show off so that's a no point nine then
it's going to drag in more variables
than perhaps we should so for this final
one that's an example of how you could
set the prize if you're very very
confident that this coefficient here
should be included in the model I'm the
only real times you should consider
being this extreme it's like the smoking
case where you have a lot of prior
information going in you've done studies
before you've seen other pieces of
evidence and you have some good reason
for it
I say yeah just forgiving those around I
think the most interesting thing is to
compare the summaries how they compare
sorry she says back up in wasted
so what we'd like to see is that the
values coming out of here are very very
close to what came out to the original
[ __ ] model
well that was suggested that our
original model was correctly specified
it would be a massive red flag if the
results coming out of this looked
different from the results that came out
to the [ __ ] model
well that would suggest is that that
model was very very dependent upon the
selection it's not very robust to
changes at that point it's kind of well
for grub's how you proceed I personally
think that these are more meaningful
things to report like another approach
might be just use as a red flag go back
to the Cox proportional hazards model
and they rethink what you do all right
so give that a go hopefully that
shouldn't be too hard
oh yeah yeah it's the probability sorry
the question is what is a prior of no
point three mean what it means is that
going in I think there's a nought point
three percent not point three chance
that that variable exists in the tree
model so I think it's quite unlikely
that the true model includes oh no not
quite so it can be included in the true
model I'm not very significant or well
yeah that's the only case so like it's
not a measure of the significance or the
importance of the variable it's just
whether or not it exists in the true
model
so behind-the-scenes how this works as
its generates every possible model in
model space and then it works out what
the probability of that model is and
then you've got that and then you can
combine it with your prior so if I say
this has a 50% chance of being true we
you tell me that it's not a good type of
model because it contains mail
then I'll down wait what I think it is
it says I go waking together yeah yeah
it's this nice tuning parameter
I know ideally again it shouldn't be too
sensitive to that if your results are
very sensitive your priors that's like
another massive red flag man yes I I'd
be happier if you used a different data
set because you're kind of counting it
twice there so you can't run it and then
update the priors and then run it again
because you're kind of like you're gonna
guarantee you're answering
I yes you could definitely do that you
could use you could calculate the most
likely model and then just say this is
the model I like that would be no
problem at all but that doesn't really
gain the Bayesian advantage and
conceptually where I come from from this
is that that is the most likely model
yes but the other models still give you
information like if you discard those
than you lose something like your best
model won't be a valid or like true
model it's not going to chief like this
platonic form I mean I'd happily
discount the prior like if God could
come down and say this is a true model
then the prior doesn't matter the thing
is that every model will always have
this probability being false and
realistically they will be false so if
you can combine like this all of these
different likes like views on the truth
together then you can get one bigger
overall picture
so the question is if you have
heterogeneous population you have two
different distributions how do you go
about separating them out it's an
excellent question is phenomenally
difficult it's just way beyond the scope
of this so I mean there is a lot more
stages you can go with this but yeah I
know the moment we're assuming that
there's this constant distribution like
it becomes really difficult really fast
when you start doing stuff like that
yeah I mean realistically nice you know
none of your models right well you need
is a model where you have this inbuilt
heterogeneity and they're not too
difficult to do like but it requires a
lot more lot more work and as if you're
interested one thing I look at our
frailty models so they try and estimate
like the propensity of a person to
convert so like these hidden or the
fighters that we can't really see so
it's quite similar to say a fixed effect
model sorry yes yeah frailty models I
mean if you're interested in more
resources I have like a whole turn so I
can send you a wide wrote it
yeah so everything we kind of brushed
over is done in more detail there apart
from the pmc stuff because the PMC
documentation is just so yeah I'd
recommend not in stone
all right I mean our screens I think yes
like this if I mean I think we field a
lot of questions yes yes oh yeah
there'll be no slots there's a huge
amount of material that's behind this
that you attention we have run into but
that will exist and just contact us
thanks very much